- [Narrator] When we think of the ocean,
we think of the beach.
But I'm speaking to one
of a handful of people
who have been to the deepest
depths of our oceans.
(phone rings)
- [Bruce] My name is Bruce Strickrott,
and I am currently the senior pilot
and manager of Alvin Operations Group
at the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution.
- [Narrator] Phew.
He pilots a submarine called Alvin,
and he works with scientists to explore
deep ocean life and terrain.
- [Bruce] Yeah, our
average depth on most dives
is between 2,500 and 3,000 meters.
- [Narrator] That's
almost two vertical miles.
This is what it feels like
to go 10,000 feet below
the water's surface.
- [Bruce] We dive, often,
down near the equator,
so it's bright and sunny.
It's early morning, it's nice.
You'll dive in the water and
you hit a color of turquoise
that I have never been
able to see anywhere else.
- [Narrator] But that
blue doesn't last long.
- [Bruce] It's easy to lose light
within five to ten minutes, easy.
- [Narrator] And you're left suspended
in seemingly black water.
- [Bruce] The sub spins the whole way down
and the whole way up, but
you don't even notice.
The only way you can tell is,
you can look at the compass
and see it's turning around.
- [Narrator] Within that
darkness, small flashes emerge.
These are from animals who
live at these extreme depths.
- [Bruce] You hit lots of bioluminescence.
The amount that you can
see outside is astounding.
- [Narrator] And then you hit the bottom.
- [Bruce] When you get to the site
that you're headed to and
you turn the lights on,
there's a huge wow factor there.
- [Narrator] In particular,
areas with geothermal vents
or these underwater
geysers, massive structures
that rise thousands of feet
up towards the surface.
- [Bruce] The view out the front
is astounding because
there's nothing like it
anywhere else on the planet, nothing.
Our perspective is
altered by our experience
because you can't go and
look at the ocean anymore
and think of it just as this
endless, flat surface of water.
You have an understanding
of what's underneath it.
(inspiring music)